wir wollen jetzt mit dem oberarzt dr
christoph spinner sprechen der in
deutschland corona patienten mit diesem
medikament im münchner klinikum rechts
der isar behandelt sprechen herr doktor
spinner
sie haben körpers wollen pakt
vorgeschlagen an der studie teilzunehmen
warum war er ein geeigneter patient ja
grundsätzlich führen wir klinische
arzneimittelwirkungen bei uns im
klinikum rechts der isar durch und alle
patienten die bei uns in unserer
einrichtung behandelt werden bekommen
sofern sie denn freiwillig teilnehmen
möchten die option an klinischen studien
zu auch hier am brandy sie ihr programm
teilzunehmen
wie sie denn so eine behandlung aus wie
verläuft diese von anfang bis ende
die behandlung findet nach einem
festgelegten plan wir sagen mit studium
protokoll dazu statt und diese wird
derzeit in verschiedenen protokollen und
ersucht die behandlung läuft in der
regel über fünf bis zehn tage sie haben
bereits dargestellt dass der applikation
intravenös erfolgt in der regel hat
mindestens ein mitarbeiter unseres
studien teams mindestens einmal am tag
mit jedem einzelnen patienten in der
klinischen studien kontakt und wir
verfolgen doch einige tage auch über die
behandlung hinaus wie sich der zustand
entwickelt haben sie denn konkrete
zahlen wir hören immer wieder dass es
eine art wundermittel sein soll gibt es
von ihnen statistiken zum erfolg dieses
medikaments wie sehr es jedoch keine
daten der kontrollierten studien
veröffentlicht worden auch wer sie sehen
daran sehr interessiert so wird es
darauf ankommen dass diese daten zeitnah
publiziert also veröffentlicht werden so
dass wir uns ein bild machen können wie
groß der einfluss von rem die 74
mit 19 wir haben ein paar technische
probleme ich bitte das zu entschuldigen
liebe zuschauer ich hoffe sie hören uns
noch herr doktor spinner
eine weitere frage die uns natürlich
alle beschäftigt gibt es nebenwirkungen
bei diesem medikament ja alles nahm mit
hp bewegungen sehr scheint es so zu sein
dass wir gut verträglich ist aber
dennoch gehört auch die untersuchung von
nebenwirkungen zur klinischen prüfung
genauso wie die wirksamkeit über welche
nebenwirkungen sprechen wir da ja bisher
ist das tatsächlich noch weiter
untersucht werden aber es man kannte
also da tun wir uns als erstes sehr sehr
schwer jetzt bereits schwere
nebenwirkungen oder andere schreiben
genau deshalb werden klinische prüfungen
durchgeführt und auch hier kann ich
ihnen genauso wie zur wirksamkeit noch
keine eindeutige aussage jetzt geben wir
wissen allerdings aus den studien die
zwei edle therapie durchgeführt wurden
dass alle nebenwirkungen mild oder auch
moderat waren
glauben sie denn dass dieses nicht
zugelassene ebola medikament rennen die
wir jetzt die ganz große hoffnung im
kampf dieses virus sein wird der einsatz
ist es wichtig ein geeignetes
arzneimittel oder mehrere arzneimittel
zu finden die im kampf gegen coop 19
wirkungsvoll den erkrankungsverlauf
verringern können
randy sie wir gehört zu den präparaten
mit denen wir hoffnungen verbinden wir
führen allerdings derzeit auch andere
arzneimittel prüfungen durch herr doktor
vielen lieben dank und grüße nach
münchen